Great. Let's dive into XML. Over the course of my
career, I've used XML in a number of different data
science projects. One of these was working with a large
collection of research articles. So, just as an example, here's the
original Google paper from Brin and Page when they were
still grad students at Stanford. Now, what I was doing in
this project is what's known as citation analysis. In citation
analysis, What we're doing is comparing the relative importance of papers
based on how many other research articles cite them. So
for example you could compare the Google paper with some of
my work. Which receives a much more modest number of
citations compared to the 11,000 that Brin and Page's paper got.
Now when I was doing my work most of the
data that I used was not publicly available. But nowadays the
same type of data is available and it's encoded as XML.
There are quite a few open access publishers, like bio-med central.
These publishers produce every article they publish both in a
print form like this, and in .xml. Now, in order to
do something like citation analysis, what we need to do
is access the bibliography for each article. So what I want
to look at as an example, is how easy it
is when you have your data encoded as .xml, to pull
out that type of data, and use it programmatically.
So let's take a look at the references for this paper.
Here are all of the other papers that this particular
research article cites, now let's take a look at the XML
version of this paper. Here is that exact same paper
only here, instead of being designed for reading, it is instead
encoded as data, let's jump down to the bibliography for
this paper. And here it is, the very beginning of the
bibliography. If we take a look at the print version of
the article again, we can see that it does, in fact,
align with what we're seeing here. So, this type
of use of XML is very much what the designers
of XML had in mind, where you have documents that
have lots of text, but text. That you want to
encode so that portions of it, at least, can
be used programatically, like we might want to do with
a bibliography of a research article. Or the author list
and other data that occurs throughout a document like this.